et sachez que le pass sanitaire européen
a été actée sous forme numérique il
devra faire état notamment d'une
vaccination contre le coc vide ou d'un
test négatif il sera nécessaire pour
passer les frontières européennes
à paris on se mobilise contre
manifestation suivie par notre reporter
jonathan - dabo trocadéro bonjour à
joseph alors quels sont les reproches
faits au passé ni terre par les
manifestants alors vous l'avez évoqué
tout d'abord il faut s'accorder sur la
définition des termes tout d'abord il
est effectivement à partir du 1er
juillet la mise en place de ce
certificat sanitaire européen qui
permettra donc de recenser les personnes
ont été vaccinées une dose de doses
jouets testés par des tests rdp serre ou
antigénique ou encore s'ils ont des
anticorps suite à une infection comme
u19 dans une
délai maximal de 180 jours c'est donc ce
certificat sanitaire euro qui sera mis
en place parmi les 27 pays de l'union
européenne et en france
il y aura aussi un passé d'extrême en
place cette fois-ci à partir du 9 juin
par le biais notamment de l'application
tous antico vise ce sera aussi possible
au format papier ce sera à peu près la
même chose savoir si vous avez été
vaccinées si vous avez été testée il se
passe ce sera nécessaire pour participer
à des manifestations publiques dans des
lieux où les gestes barrière ne peuvent
pas être respecté on pense notamment à
des stades de fous des festivals de
musique des endroits où il y aurait plus
de 1000 personnes alors se passe
sanitaire français et européens
il provoque de nombreuses inquiétudes
ici à cette manifestation au trocadéro
je vous propose d'écouter certains
médias
le plus gros porc problème c'est que
plus personne n'est libre on oublie on
oblige
et attendez moi je souhaite continuer à
vivre et à faire ce que je veux et tant
pis si je ne suis pas si je ne peux pas
voyager et bah tant pis je préfère ma
liberté de conscience plutôt que ma
liberté d'aller et venir
je ne participerai pas à cette mascarade
quand on nous dit c'est provisoire je ne
crois plus au provisoire depuis un an
tout ce qui devait être provisoire est
en train de me dire définitif l'état
d'urgence a fait donc presque ça fait
plus d'un an
voilà donc c'est un véritable danger
qu'on se retrouve dans une société où
ceux qui ont un pass anitea pourront
vivre et les autres on sera exclu il ya
un pas que les manifestants qui sont au
taquet concernant se passer ni terre car
la défenseure des droits elle-même a
émis certaines réserves notamment
concernant la gestion des données
sanitaires des français mais aussi l'a
évoqué un risque de discrimination des
français concernant l'accès dans les
lieux publics liés et bien j'en attends
pour toutes ces précisions je rappelle
que vous étiez accompagné de l'uqat ua
pour les images merci
[Musique]